hi so welcome again this is Andre amia
for the Udacity webinar on
entrepreneurialship so today's agenda
we're going to be talking about the
entrepreneurial mindset the top 10 think
attributes of an entrepreneur the growth
mindset which is ultimately what that
mindset is about do a little quiz with
that and then we'll talk about what goes
into a business plan and a marketing
plan again my name is Andre Amaya and
I'm the presenter today about
entrepreneurship excuse me and by the
way please feel free to ask any sort of
questions and interact in the chat room
and we'll have an opportunity to speak
with each other later also give me one
second I want to make sure that
everybody just gets admitted immediately
okay I think when people come in now it
should be okay um okay so just to make
sure everybody can see the slide
Diane people can see the slide
chimey let me know in the chat box if
everybody sees it
okay good thank you so the first thing
so what I want you to do actually is to
have a little piece of paper out in
front of you and I want you to give
yourself a score when we go through
these three being yes that's very much
so that describes me to being yeah maybe
maybe I probably but maybe and one being
wow that is really not me okay now if
there's a lot of that's really really
not me don't be panicked about it this
is we're trying to discern whether this
is a good match for you or not basically
so try to be honest with yourself and
whether these are attributes that you
would say are true about you so the
first one is personal initiative first
entrepreneurs are not are doers and
they're really not dreamers an
impersonal initiative has to do with
this drive to just do it basically so in
this case number one give yourself a 3-2
or one whether that would describe you
or not
second thing perseverance so one of the
singles biggest factors in perseverance
and is total dedication to the venture
thousands of examples of people who have
tried to succeed but then have just
given up so give yourself again a score
of three to one third one ability to set
and achieve goals
the ability to establish goals and then
focus on those goals is critical goals
must be realistic attainable and
measurable and the entrepreneur must
then be able to establish a vision of
success successful entrepreneurs do not
think about failure okay now we'll go to
the next slide
next one is ability to recognize and
solve problems so this is give it a
three if you're really not intimidated
by the number or the severity of the
problems that you might face
entrepreneurs tend to recognize an
attack and solve problems based on their
need to achieve
five asking for help and using feedback
this one's actually really really
important or for many things but what
this has to do with and there's a little
picture of this over here the feedback
loop is not being full hardly foolhardy
in your pursuit of a problem or a goal
realizing the time is not unlimited and
that making a decision is still a
decision they ask for help when it is
needed and so think about whether you
have the inclination to ask for help
when you need it the next one is
learning from both successes and
failures entrepreneurs learn from both
both of these they don't hide their
errors instead they analyze the causes
and learn from them successful
entrepreneurs become what I like to call
like conscious computers okay they know
where they were successful and how to
build on that success and they know
where they failed and how to prevent
similar failure in the future
again give yourself a little bit of a
score there
okay we have four more next one is
self-reliant and self-confident so this
is
trusting in the fate of your venture
basically and your own abilities to
achieve it this is not the difference
between being confident and cocky is not
that great the confidence leads to
success in cockiness leads to failure so
it's it may be splitting hairs to some
degree but confidence counts for
something here moderate risk taking and
risk sharing so effective entrepreneurs
generally prefer to take moderate
calculated risks not ones that are so
large that they're losing everything
putting it all on the line basically and
not too small that they they're not
having any skin in the game or any stake
really
number nine is tolerance of uncertainty
and ambiguity
the ability to make effective decisions
based in an uncertain environment
taking it with stride viewing it as a
challenge
appearing to thrive in this type of
environment
so time is again not unlimited you have
to make decisions but being able to live
with that ambiguity in the last one and
there are many others but these are the
ten that I chose that I think are the
most most significant is a team builder
this is about not taking credit alone
for your success but being able to share
in that success recognizing that you're
not able to build a business by them by
yourself and actively recruit teams or
build teams I had businesses before one
of the most important things that I have
recognized in building a business is
knowing what your strong at and knowing
what your we get and knowing when to
hire out basically and not try to do
everything yourself
recognizing that this is not possible to
do everything is really important
so what this goes to is the idea of a
growth mindset and whether you're in
this growth mindset or not you look at
the slide that I have here
about how your intelligence is developed
whether you learn from criticism or you
ignore it whether you look at things as
I want to master them basically or you
think that that's a fruitless venture
so if you take a look at that this is
this is what I'm talking about when
you're talking about growth mindset
which has a lot to do with
entrepreneurialism so
you should have scored up about what
your your scores are right now and if
you want you can share it in the group
again the idea was giving yourself a
three if you really agreed that was you
too not so sure but maybe and one
oh boy that really definitely is not me
you
and can everybody hear okay
[Music]
you
I think that um if if you you can
probably leave the breakout room
yourself at the bottom of the screen and
the right-hand side there we go okay
perfect
lourdes one two three thank you have
everyone
Andrea we can't hear you okay I'm
unmuted now can you hear me
yeah yes okay and can you see it slide
also I just want to make sure about that
now slide interesting okay and you'd see
this slide
oh there we go
okay sorry yeah all right is not my
strong point at least mr. doom and
trying to work with this so I want to
talk about now things to consider in
creating a business plan for yourself so
it's one thing to dream and it's another
thing to practically put down what is
most important for you to consider in
creating a business plan and considering
a marketing plan so these are things
more to take notes on and to think about
okay so why do we create business plans
we create business plans so that we have
a roadmap to success and so that we're
not doing it blind
we're not grabbing and going we're
talking about creating something that
can be lasting and they can sustain you
that's the idea of creating a business
basically and so these are a few things
to keep in mind failure to develop a
realistic business plan that's basic
okay having a sense of I what success
will look like to you okay and actually
writing this down
reasons that business plans don't work
is mismanagement of funds deciding I
forget who it was I think was nyla SH
was talking about yeah he's running a
family right now and working for people
how much money does he have to put aside
to start his own business responsibly
okay
concept to not being that concept needs
to be good lack of market or need when
we're talking to who was it now I'm not
seeing her name anyway the the lovely
lady at the end I who is talking about
like who needs it basically you know
figuring out if people need what it is
that you would like to sell being
insufficiently aggressive oh sorry
oh yeah can you all hear me no we can't
Joseph oh it sorry Lourdes Lourdes thank
you I couldn't see Lourdes his name also
just not having enough money and not
having enough of the skills that are
necessary to run a business now as I've
mentioned before with Stavros knowing
what it is that you're not strong at and
knowing what it is that you are strong
at and being able to compensate for that
that makes up for that meaning not
having the necessary personal or
business skills that doesn't mean that
that's a permanent situation that means
that that's something to address
other questions to ask yourself will
this business be profitable and can I
afford to do it can I live with the
projected cash flow
how does the rate of return that is
anticipated let me move this anticipated
profit represent compared to other ways
to invest so at the end of the day if
you have five dollars in your bank
account and you want to start a business
with that five dollars is that the best
use of the five dollars is it better to
invest in another way so something to
just consider we only have so much
capital in our lives to start with and
how what is the best way to grow that
basically one might be having a business
and one might be doing something else
with that investment is this a business
that you want to provide your full
income also maybe this is a
supplementary business maybe this is
your full-time job but this is something
to consider how much you actually need
for it to take care of your entire gross
income
their questions to ask what can go wrong
I could have no customers for example or
and how likely is that that nobody needs
what it is that I want to provide what
if I think this is actually one of the
more important things what can be done
about it before it goes wrong so
thinking through this whole issue of
what are the different things that could
go wrong and then thinking about okay
well let's say that does go wrong what
are my backup plans what are the what
are the different ways that I will go to
address those issues thinking about this
at the beginning will help you so much
later because you'll have a plan to go
to if something does go wrong now
granted things can go wrong that you
have no idea of predicting for example
this this virus that's out there right
now I have a business that my partner is
going down to a very very large
convention this week hundred thousand
people are supposed to be at it now
they're thinking forty to sixty percent
are going to be at it that could be
looked at as unsuccessful from the
beginning instead what we're doing is
we're looking at what the pitch is and
how to take advantage of the fact that
half the people are going to be that
they expected to be there
in fact it may play into what we're
selling that much more because we're
saying hey you don't have to do this
person-to-person you can do this on
video basically so things that can go
wrong what are ways for you to pivot the
last question on here what is my
long-term exit strategy that can
actually be really informative as to how
serious a business this is if you can
have an exit strategy so is it that you
need to buy equipment and that you'll
have equipment and some sort of capital
investment that you could sell in the
end and sell to another company will you
have a customer list for example that
you would want to sell to another
company to get out of it if you have a
partnership you know has that been the
habit has the exit strategy been worked
into the partnership so that it's clear
if one wants to exit or another one's to
exit how that will happen but mainly
looking at the thing that you are
creating as something that can be passed
to somebody else does it have that sort
of gravitas basically that you will have
something to hand to somebody else for
them to take over the business or does
the business die with you and and if the
business dies with you the business dies
with you knowing that that's the case
but give some consideration to what is
it that you're creating as an asset that
you could possibly sell to somebody else
and say this is an asset and if you
continue to work it the way I did it'll
continue to be successful so creating an
exit strategy
you
so these things here some of these are
just classic thing if you look up what's
in a business plan this is what's in a
business plan not sure if my zooms Theo
there let me get the zoom thing out of
there
your missions your value statements
executive summary is just who you are
basically or who the people in your
business are
what is what is it that you're selling
what is the description of your goods
we're going to talk more about marketing
plans marketing strategy and sales
strategy is there a sales cycle or what
you're doing
so really dialing down into the sales
plan talking about what the financial
plan might be the organization any sort
of legal considerations you need to have
Human Resources plan and an appendix may
be patents and so on that you need now
why create I put all this out here this
is stuff that you can look up yourself
as to what goes into a business plan but
the reason I'm putting it out there is
that the business plan people often look
at it is like well I need to create that
for somebody else if I'm asking for
money for example from somebody they
want to see a business plan what I'm
telling you is that a business plan is a
good thing to have for yourself and to
go through this for yourself thinking
through these questions and who it is
you are what what is your sales plan
what is your marketing plan what are
your assets what are the finances that
we're talking about what is the
operations plan that we that you're
planning on doing what's what sort of
allocations do you need for that when
we're talking about a one-person band so
to speak that you're starting your own
business if you go through this exercise
of really breaking down things really
considering all of these different
issues that you see on the screen here
you'll be so much better at being able
to respond to things when they don't go
exactly your way or the other the other
side of this is by going through this
you go through figuring out who is my
market what is it that I exactly have to
sell what is it that distinguishes me in
some sort of fashion without doing that
you're just sort of like hey I'm going
to sell software I want to develop
something but there's nothing it's not
based in a whole plan basically and
that's where this marketing plan
basics come into mine knowing who your
customers are give me one second knowing
how to price your products knowing the
method and scale of production and the
timing this might be a great time to
start a business from home and we were
talking about this before with Lourdes
the demand for totally new technology if
you know there's a market for diverting
from the old to the new this is part of
the research that needs to be done you
know are people ready for it and do you
have a way of speaking about it even if
they want AI for example maybe people
may not know they wanted until they know
what the capacity is and from knowing
the capacity then they might be like oh
of course I want that I don't care what
you call it you could call it you know
blue red yellow it doesn't matter but
this is the sort of capacity I would
love to have and I'll pay money for
so how do you do that with a market
study what is the viable market for you
that the does if the product exists
already what is the timing and are you
sufficiently distinctive to attract the
sales you anticipate I coach a lot of
people who are coming out of learning
about technology and not having a lot of
experience yet and they're trying to
figure out well how do I get the
experience and oftentimes I say well why
don't you start your own freelance
business which is what you all have
interests in here
like and if you want to be a web
developer decide what your niche is
maybe it comes from your background
maybe it comes from something that
you're particularly interested in now
but let's say that you like doing nails
and that you've had a whole background
in doing nails but now you're a web
developer and you're on front-end web
development maybe your focus should be
all a nail clients that's what your
niche is so that when they see you they
identify with you and they know you're
there
person to hire so they can see
themselves in you being very general
about things not knowing who your
audience is not knowing who your market
is not defining it clearly that is a way
to not get customers basically I told
you all that I dealt in film for a long
time we used to say that in film you
need to have at least two audiences that
are clearly defined that you're going
for if you want to bring people and
sitting down in seats so a general movie
that has no target audience has no
audience there's no way it may be a
great movie but there's no way to get
people to go to see it it's exactly the
same thing in a business you have to get
people to go see it by being able to
identify what those markets are and play
to them it doesn't have to be just one
it could be multiple but you have to
define them
everybody doesn't want whatever it is
that you sell
so part of what we do here with the
market strategy is comparing your
business to the competition being able
to sorry
okay I will try to figure that out okay
your question Lord says could a strategy
be to first to be freelance to get an
idea where your mark yeah you can also
test the market that way but in this
fight I'm talking about comparing your
business to the competition seeing what
else is out there basically first and
seeing how it is you want to distinguish
yourself and make present yourself as
unique um one of the other things to
consider and I guess AI is one of those
do you have to be really big to compete
or can you be small to compete
not first many things you can be small
to compete if you're your target is
small businesses you know that they have
limited capabilities in that way and
limited desires you can reach them or do
you need huge assets to be able to
create what it is that you want to
create to be realistic about that
and as you asked like could this be a
way of figuring out what your market is
absolutely but keep refining what those
descriptions are figuring out where am I
getting responses what type of people my
getting responses from is this my market
now have I started to define it
differently or this isn't quite my
market and I need to I need to change
what my materials are I need to appeal
if I'm an ale if I want to appeal to
nail shops for example you know it am I
appealing to women owned shops properly
do I note that I know that's my business
for example or is it that nail shops
actually aren't women-owned they're men
owned and what I'm doing is I'm playing
into I should be playing into immense
sense of sensibility more than a woman's
Sensibility perhaps a man that's being
very general but I'm saying like really
no it basically really know who it is
you're selling to you can have profiles
of them company and personality was
so once you've decided that they're a
viable market for your product exists
you need to time how you want to get
into it
and make sure that you are definitely
distinctive enough so that people see
you sometimes people are afraid to like
I don't want to turn off people I I
don't want to like I don't want to
eliminate anybody right um
you do want to eliminate a lot of people
you want to find what your target
audience is and you want to play to that
audience and as I said it could be
multiple audiences but it isn't
everybody I would I have a business that
does neurofeedback everybody who has a
brain could benefit from neurofeedback
however we had to decide we want to
appeal to mothers who have children who
have ADHD for example okay
this is a specific market so that those
mothers can identify that they want to
give their child an advantage basically
with this system however everybody with
the brain could benefit from it that
doesn't help me find a market or define
a market or play to a market so you you
must find the market and and then
develop a sales strategy around that
market
okay so now I would like to know if you
have any questions or and and any
thoughts that people can share with each
other about this because I think it was
bare barrel who has had businesses
before and knows what the challenges
could be let's see if I can figure out
how to unmute everybody not sure see if
I have the ability to make sure to
unmute yourself also because I'm
clicking on mood on you
you
hi Andrea can you hear me yes I can so
my question to have a couple of
questions thank you for the helpful
presentation my questions are I would
like to get our checklist like you know
in terms of like okay this is what you
need to do first before doing that kind
of a thing you know like you had a good
slide there with all the business plan
yeah I would like you know I understand
like okay you go to first register your
business or like you know find a lawyer
or like you know what are the sure so I
would like to answer that I can answer
that question as far as the United
States goes to a good degree but I can't
answer that question for everywhere in
the world I'm sure Stavros has a better
sense of like how do you go about
setting up a business in Greece and how
do you go and register your business
name for example I'm the the general
process in the United States and maybe
this is transferrable on some level is
you need to make sure one your name is
clear so that the title is clear that so
there's not another business called nyla
shazam enterprises basically you know
right where you are that you're in
competition with and a lawyer can do
that for you and a title search can do
that for you as well
if you don't want to pay a lawyer to do
that second is you need to decide
whether you're going what kind of
business you're going to be are you
going to be a DBA which is a doing
business as business or are you going to
be an LLC or an LLC for everybody who's
not from the United States is a business
that can protect your other assets
basically so if somebody comes after
your business and wants to exact
something they don't have access to your
house and to your family's money
basically they have access to whatever
the assets are in the business so it's a
way to protect your family's assets by
not doing a DBA meaning of doing
business as
there are a couple of variations on that
for that you may or may not need a
lawyer to set it up the next thing you
need to do is have a identification
number so that taxes can be paid and
people can pay you and and give you
money basically and you can give them
forms again don't know how it's done
throughout the rest of the world exactly
but probably you need to have some sort
of number identifying you with the tax
authorities that you are doing business
so now you have a name you are able to
have a bank account you're able to be
paid by people and your and you have
your partnership agreement set up or
your your your operating agreement set
up okay so you're at that point then
there's the factor of patents and so on
I don't know whether any of you need
that want that but then that's what I
would get into next is how do you
protect whatever the intellectual
property is that you've created if if
that is the type of business that you
are talking about creating okay um and
then the rest of it once you're up in
sort of up and going in that way the
rest of it has to do with your business
plan meaning figuring out and and being
clear on what the market is what your
time frame is what your sales cycle is
going to be I how you're going to
position yourself basically how you're
going to allocate the different assets
that you have into these different
places that you need to allocate them
and buy assets I mean not just money but
also your time how much time you want to
spend out in and how much time you you
want to spend them and you were like and
if it takes more than this amount of
time I'm farming out and I'm paying
someone else to do this part because I
can't do everything so wasteful that was
a verbal way of talking about like what
are the first steps basically business
plans I don't I don't know how to send
that to you
on here I guess I can put it maybe Diane
has a brilliant idea but um maybe I can
send something through the courier hub
as an attachment and what I'll do is
I'll go to the career hub where we do
chatting and I'll put something in there
because I just know how to do that I'm
not quite sure how I can do it otherwise
okay nyle ish thank you is there some
place where I can get some like sample
business plans so that it's like a good
template of like okay this is what you
need to address in this particular point
they are also so specific I've seen
dozens in my lifetime different
I will give you are you in the United
States stylish yeah I am okay there's an
app there is a resource that let me just
write it down in the chat room I'll
score also did that come through score s
CEO ar e I'm not sure
Diane if it did yeah we could have
Rachel email them score and the other
group I was gonna say it's a small
business small business what is it
Association of America anyway score is
the Society for retired executives and
what they're designed to do is they are
designed to they're all doing it as a
volunteer work they're in all major
cities and a lot of minor cities and
they are executives who have retired
from their business thank you and are
offering their services to help you
develop your business okay and they can
help you with marketing if that's what
you need help with or a business plan if
that's what you need help with but there
are assets out there and people who are
willing to help you develop these things
as well SBA thank you it's the SBA
that's always going to say okay any
other
questions huh
though very difficult to have a business
plan oh my god that's so terrible I have
a friend who's a video videographer in
Athens and he was telling now this is a
few years ago when I was there that he
sometimes he gets paid and sometimes I
don't know six months before he gets
paid who knows very hard for him to run
a business based on the people not
paying in any sort of timely fashion
basically because the economy is tanking
so many minutes so many so many ways so
is it easy to start a business and you
pay for non-us residents no I don't
think so the plus how are you going to
enforce not being here even if you
started a business here and let's say
you have a partner here that that you
know site sets up your business and you
are your the a partner in it so then
you're under US laws and you need to
enforce US laws which need to be
enforced here basically so that's a very
short answer to say like in not not so
sure that that's that way around it
exactly um however one thing I would
consider being in Greece is is there a
country in the EU that is maybe more
conducive to business and for setting
yourself up in that way and one of the
things that we do and I don't know
whether it's done in Europe exactly yes
there are different states that are
better to set up your business depending
on the heads of the states and you can
go about doing that
basically to save money okay but I would
wonder in with Greece you know should
you set up something in the Netherlands
instead
does that make more sense yeah and maybe
and I mean the nice thing about it is
they may be a good part of your market
if you set yourself up somewhere else
also even though you're providing
injuries thank you
how do you value your talent both one of
the things you do so Lord of staffs how
do you value your talent and not
undersell your talents and I think
something to keep in mind here is one
what is that what will the market allow
and what did it you're getting out of it
so when I talk to the just beginning and
they're trying to develop a portfolio of
success you know the portfolio of work
that they can show other people to sell
other people on their work in a way it
really doesn't matter what they charge
for that I
it's not about undervaluing their over
valuing their talent it's a matter of
you need this done I need to show that I
can do this
so that I could get other people to pay
me for it so for the first few sort of
adventures I wouldn't look at it as a
money I would look at it as creating a
project basically to show others and to
be able to position yourself it's being
able to do the work why do people decide
to fine on with you they decide because
they see it others have signed on
basically they see themselves in you on
some level they see that you're talking
to them and they need to have confidence
that you can deliver the delivering so
how do you create that confidence you
have you need to have something first so
I can answer to your question how do you
value your talent I think you decide
based on the project what it is you need
from
first and then what will the market bear
is another thing and whether you're
offering something that's rarefied that
you can charge more that nobody else in
the market is offering and therefore
it's that much more for something
distinctive about you it may be that
you're an award-winning creator I it may
be that you are you have something tool
that you've developed nobody else has
developed um but obviously there you get
to charge more if there's something
totally distinctive that you have that
nobody else has I hope that answers your
question I wasn't trying to punt how us
values thank you none at all any other
questions okay let me just let you know
about there's another webinar coming up
on March 9th boosting your chances of
landing throat job I can sign up for
that one I'm not sure who's giving it
I'm sorry to say and that is all she
wrote today thank you joining us Thank
You Diane for helping answer questions I
appreciate that
and I hope that you join again we will
sprout how I think what I'm gonna do is
put some resources on in the chat room
because I don't know if we can know all
exactly and email addresses to be able
to send you more information about
business plans so take a look there pay
attention there a little bit okay that's
like your knowledge thank you
[Music]